bien madame le Premier ministre chers
collègues nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir Madame Elisabeth borne
Premier ministre en tant qu' ancienne
ministre chargé des transports et
ancienne ministre du travail de l'emploi
et de l'insertion madame la première
année je vous souhaite la bienvenue je
vous remercie de vous êtes rendu
disponible pour répondre à nos questions
vous le savez à partir du 10 juillet
2022 plusieurs membres du consortium
international des journalistes
d'investigation on publie ce qu'il est
désormais convenu d'appeler les uber
fails s'appuyant sur 124000 documents
internes à leur entreprise américaine
d'été de 2013 et 2017 cette enquête a
dénoncé les méthodes de lobbying de la
société uber pour implanter en France
comme dans de nombreux pays des
véhicules transports avec chauffeurs VTC
venant concurrencer le secteur
traditionnel du transport public
particulier de personnes réservées
jusqu'à leur au taxi dans ce contexte
notre commission d'enquête poursuit un
double objet d'une part identifié
l'ensemble des actions de lobbying
menées par uber pour s'implanter en
France le rôle des décideurs publics de
l'époque et émettre des recommandations
concernant l'encadrement des relations
entre décideurs publics et représentants
d'intérêt
d'autre part évaluer les conséquences
économiques sociales environnementales
du développement du modèle uber
numérisation en France et les réponses
apportées à apporter par les décideurs
publics en la matière pour comprendre
les enjeux répondre à ces objectifs
notre commission à procéder à plus de 70
missions entendues plus de 110 personnes
qui s'agissent du lanceur d'alerte
monsieur Marc Magan des journalistes à
l'origine de l'enquête des représentants
de chauffeurs de taxi VTC des livreurs
syndicalistes avocats magistrats de la
Cour de cassation des dirigeants de
nombreuses plateformes numériques des
sous-traitants des directeurs
d'administratifs d'administration
d'autorité administratives indépendantes
telles que la HTV la CNIL l'Autorité de
la concurrence des experts tels que
Monsieur froin monsieur Mettling
d'anciens députés membres de cabinets
ministériel ou anciens Premier ministre
économiste et j'en passe
dans la mesure où vous avez été ministre
en charge des transports entre mai 2017
et juillet 2019 notre Commission a
estimé nécessaire de recueillir votre
témoignage sur les conditions de la
concurrence entre les VTC et taxis sur
la mise en oeuvre de la loi grand
Guillaume du 30 décembre 2016
notre commission d'enquête a notamment
constaté qu'après plusieurs
interventions légitimes entre 2013 et
2017 notamment la loi thévenou 2014 la
loi grand Guillaume de 2016 le secteur
du transport public particulier de
personnes et désormais bien encadré
réguler à trouver un équilibre après
l'arrivée du secteur des VTC en France
comme dans tous les autres marchés
européens ou nord-américains comparable
on relève encore des difficultés qui
peuvent liées au manque de données
pertinentes pour appréhender l'évolution
en valeur en volume du marché de la
réservation préalable sur lequel taxi
VTC sont en concurrence malgré certaines
exigences de la Loi ganglione pourraient
vous expliquer cette situation votre
audition nous aussi paru nécessaire car
vous avez et ensuite été en charge du
ministère du Travail à compter du 6
juillet 2020 vous avez donc été conduite
à fixer les priorités de l'inspection du
travail vous avez été à l'origine de la
création de l'autorité des relations
sociales des plateformes d'emploi l'ARP
à la suite des recommandations de
Monsieur Franck et puis de l'État force
mai et vous avez notamment contribué à
préparer la position de la France sur le
projet de directive européenne relative
à l'amélioration des conditions de
travail dans le cadre du travail des
plateformes pouvez-vous nous indiquer
plus précisément de quelle manière vous
avez encouragé en tant que ministre du
Travail une meilleure régulation de
l'activité des plateformes numériques de
mobilité leur relation sociale avec leur
partenaire sous le plus souvent des
auto-entrepreneurs indépendants quel fut
votre réaction au ministère du Travail à
la suite de différents arrêts de la Cour
de cassation conduisant à requalifier
certains chauffeurs VTC ou livreurs sous
le statut de salarié compte tenu de
l'existence d'un lien de subordination
dans lequel il se trouvait et qu'il est
aujourd'hui votre position la position
de la France concernant les propositions
de la Commission européenne pour
interdire une présomption de salariat
des travailleurs de plateformes dans
tous ces secteurs d'activité par
ailleurs vous avez dévoilé mardi dernier
des objectifs chiffrés la trajectoire de
décarbonation de la France à l'horizon
2030 avez-vous pu au préalable évaluer
les conséquences sur l'environnement de
l'ubérisation d'une partie de l'économie
pouvez-vous nous indiquer si le secteur
du trait de 3p de la livraison seront
concernés par ces juristes de
décarbonation enfin comme vous le savez
notre commission d'enquête a beaucoup
travaillé sur les relations entre
représentants intérêts et décideurs
publics elle a recueilli de nombreuses
propositions nous en avons transmis un
certain nombre visons à visant à
renforcer la transparence de la vie
publique pouvez-vous nous indiquer
quelle serait la position du
Gouvernement sur ces différentes
propositions à noter bien sûr que le
cadre a évolué avec la loi Sapin 2 et la
création de la chatvp depuis l'effet
d'ailleurs qui a été relaté dans les
uber five nous aurons bien sûr d'autres
questions à vous poser mes collègues je
vous propose d'entamer nos discussions à
ce stade je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole je vous rappelle
madame la Première ministre que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires imposent
aux personnes auditionnées par une
commission enquête de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité je vous inviter à activer
votre micro levez la main droite et dire
je le jure
je le jure merci Madame la première mi
je vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés donc avant de répondre plus
précisément à vos questions je
souhaiterais revenir en quelques mots
sur les différentes actions menées
depuis l'émergence des plateformes pour
mieux les réguler et mieux protéger des
travailleurs donc vous le savez
l'émergence des plateformes est encore
très récente en France c'est en 2011
donc il y a un peu plus de 10 ans cuber
a commencé à opérer dans notre pays ces
plateformes ont considérablement modifié
nos pratiques et l'organisation de
certains secteurs elles ont créé de
nouvelles offres parfois en concurrence
avec des acteurs déjà présents je pense
en particulier au VTC elles ont parfois
provoqué un changement d'échelle
considérable pour certains services je
pense notamment aux livraisons à
domicile
j'ajoute que rapidement ces plateformes
auto-cycrées de nouveaux emplois et des
possibilités d'insertion professionnelle
en 12 ans le modèle des plateformes a
considérablement évolué il s'agissait au
départ souvent de job étudiant ou de
travail d'appoint c'est désormais
souvent la seule source de revenus
notamment chez les livreurs et les
rémunérations ont été tirées vers le bas
du fait d'une concurrence féroce entre
les différents acteurs
ces évolutions ont posé des questions en
France comme partout en Europe aux
États-Unis où les mêmes phénomènes
étaient à l'œuvre
le législateur a d'abord cherché à
apaiser les tensions entre les VTC et
les taxis qui s'estiment victime d'une
concurrence déloyale c'est l'objet de la
loi du premier octobre 2014 relative au
taxi et aux VTC la question du cadre
social a ensuite émergé la loi travail
en 2016 a apporté des premières réponses
avec la participation des plateformes à
la formation et à une assurance contre
les accidents de travail et avec le
droit de se syndiquer et de faire grève
néanmoins il ne s'agissait encore que de
mesures aux effets limités et
insuffisants face à l'ampleur des
changements en cours
comme ministre en charge des transports
puis de la transition écologique à
travers la loi d'orientation des
mobilités et ensuite comme ministre du
Travail je n'ai eu de cesse de prendre
des mesures pour mieux réguler ses
activités et protéger des travailleurs
des plateformes
je me suis fixé trois principes
de télétravailleurs des plateformes de
réels droits sociaux
permettre à ceux qui souhaitaient être
indépendants de l'être réellement et
bien sûr faire confiance au dialogue
social pour faire émerger des solutions
efficaces et adaptées
c'est dans cette optique que la loi
d'orientation des mobilités a
considérablement
œuvré à rétablir l'équilibre entre les
travailleurs et les plateformes je pense
aux droits de refuser une prestation au
droit de choisir ses plages d'activité
et d'inactivité ou encore aux
protections contre les représailles et
les ruptures
communistes du travail la construction
d'un dialogue social juste et effectif a
fait partie de mes grands chantiers
ainsi en avril 2021 et en avril 2022
deux ordonnances ont été prises pour
construire un cadre de dialogue social
et de négociation collective dans les
secteurs des VTC et de la livraison
avec ces textes nous avons pu établir
des normes obligatoires pour réguler les
effets de la concurrence sur les droits
des travailleurs comme peuvent le faire
les conventions collectives pour les
salariés
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs sont en
place depuis septembre 2022
j’ajoute qu'en tant que ministre j'ai
installé l'autorité des relations
sociales des plateformes d'emploi pour
aider et accompagner la négociation
collective
près de 125 000 personnes étaient
inscrites sur les listes électorales
pour participer aux élections des
travailleurs des plateformes près de 40
000 chauffeurs et près de 85 000
livreurs
aujourd'hui les résultats sont là deux
accords ont déjà été conclus pour les
VTC pour établir un tarif minimal de
course proche de celui des taxis et pour
donner plus de moyens aux représentant
des travailleurs pour exercer leur
mission
quant au livreur se sont trois accords
qui ont été trouvés en 6 mois pour une
rémunération minimale de l'activité sur
le dialogue social et contre les
déconnexions arbitraires
pour autant je le sais nous avons
réalisé uniquement une partie du chemin
j'engage évidemment les plateformes à
aller plus loin notamment dans le cadre
de la négociation d'une rémunération
minimale d'activités qui a commencé pour
les VTC
et je voudrais souligner que ce modèle
de dialogue social est unique en Europe
et qui permet de faire de la France un
des pays les plus protecteurs des droits
des travailleurs des plateformes
et c'est bien le gouvernement qui a
donné un cadre et permis les conditions
d'une discussion plus équilibrée entre
plateformes et travailleurs
j'ajoute qu'en parallèle de ce modèle de
négociation collective unique nous avons
décidé de mener une politique de
contrôle soutenu ces contrôles ont mis
en évidence le recours indirect par les
plateformes à des travailleurs en
situation irrégulière à travers la
pratique de sous-location de compte
cette pratique illégale bafoue les
principes de nos droits sociaux en
perçant en plaçant les personnes en
situation irrégulière dans de véritables
situations d'exploitation nous avons
exigé une mobilisation forte des
plateformes pour un meilleur contrôle
notamment en régulant mieux les
sous-location de compte que j'évoquais à
l'instant nous avons obtenu des
engagements des plateformes
matérialisées dans une charte qu'elles
ont signé
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vous l'indiquais au début de mon
intervention tous les pays ont été
confrontés au développement des
plateformes nous avons donc travaillé au
niveau européen à bâtir un cadre commun
en décembre 2021 à quelques semaines de
la présidence française du Conseil de
l'Union européenne la Commission a
proposé un projet de directive
la Commission a bien sûr fait des choix
de fonds mais elle pouvait au terme du
Traité des traités ne passaient que par
la présomption de salariat en conformité
avec sa compétence en matière de
protection des travailleurs
comme présidente du conseil des
ministres du travail j'ai porté ce
projet de directives et j'avais alors
fait preuve naturellement de la
neutralité qui s'impose à la présidence
à partir de juillet 2022 la France a
formulé des propositions d'amendement
notamment pour disposer de critères de
présomption de salariats cohérents et
adaptés à notre droit et pour respecter
notre cadre de négociation collective
qui fonctionne bien comme en témoigne
les cinq accords obtenus
en décembre dernier nous étions prêts à
approuver le texte de compromis proposé
par la présidence tchèque mais nous
avons nous avons été confrontés à une
minorité de blocage aujourd'hui sous
président suédoise nous continuons à
faire des propositions constructives et
nous souhaitons qu'un texte puisse
aboutir
mesdames et messieurs les députés voilà
en quelques mots les grandes lignes de
l'action de la France pour réguler les
pratiques des plateformes depuis leur
arrivée en 2011 à chaque étape nous
avons réagi pour éviter la concurrence
déloyale vis-à-vis des acteurs déjà
installés et nous avons pris des
décisions fortes pour protéger des
travailleurs et leur permettre de faire
entendre leur voix c'est le fil rouge de
l'action du gouvernement et c'est la
volonté que j'ai porté dans toutes les
fonctions que j'ai occupées je vous
remercie je me tiens naturellement à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci madame la Première ministre je
reviendrai sur quelques-unes des
questions que j'avais soulevées dans mon
introduction notamment le débat en cours
au niveau européen sur la directive de
présentation salariale nous venons
deditionner le miser transport Clément
Beaune ancien secrétaire d'État aux
Affaires européennes qui est souligné à
quel point la France avait été moteur
sur le fait qu'il y ait une régulation
au niveau une harmonisation au niveau
européen de la question de la protection
sociale des travailleurs des plateformes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un
peu de du rôle de la France dans ce
débat et de la position de la France et
peut-être dire un mot aussi même si
c'est pas directement lié évidemment à
vos attributions en tant que mise du
travail ministre de transport de la
question de l'encadrement des relations
entre les représentants d'entreprises
privées et les décideurs publics et si
vous voyez des voies d'approfondissement
ou d'amélioration suite à la loi Sapin 2
et la création de la chatvp
alors d'abord sur le projet directive
comme je l'ai indiqué la proposition a
été faite par la Commission en décembre
2021 c'est à dire juste avant la
présidence française et donc pendant
cette dernière nous aurions pu mettre le
texte de côté parce qu'on nous reproche
souvent de vouloir bloquer le texte en
fait c'est tout le contraire puisque en
tant que Président
nous avons organisé pas moins de 7
groupes de travail qui ont permis
d'avancer sur ce texte et de présenter
au Conseil de juin 2022 un rapport de
progrès avant de passer le relais à la
présidence tchèque
[Musique]
subordination alors il peut être regardé
comme indépendant donc nous sommes en
phase avec cette approche qui est bon
sens toute la question est de savoir
comment déterminer les critères qui
permettent de constater qu'il y a
subordination ou pas si on a des
critères trop généraux et qui sont
insuffisamment précis il n'est pas
possible d'apprécier la réalité du lien
et de distinguer les différents cas de
figure qui se présentent et dont tirer
des conséquences sur les deux options
salariat ou pas donc selon nous
l'objectif du texte serait manqué si
alors que le texte est supposé apporté
de la sécurité juridique en clarifiant
les situations sur la base d'une liste
précise de critères si l'appréciation et
la qualification reste floue et que
c'est Infiné au juge qu'il appartient de
trancher les situations donc notre
position est claire on est engagé dans
la recherche d'une position équilibrée
sur le texte qui permettent à la fois de
favoriser l'emploi de lutter contre les
faux indépendants et à l'inverse de
préserver le statut des véritables
travailleurs indépendants qui souhaitent
le rester tout en protégeant le modèle
des accords collectifs qui portent ses
fruits ce que je précise un finalement
ce texte
contrairement à l'approche qu'on a pu
avoir en France ne permet pas de créer
des droits collectifs pour les
travailleurs des plateformes sauf si les
critères qui figurent dans le texte
permettent de les requalifier en
salariat mais sinon le texte ne mène pas
le chemin que nous avons mené en France
pour permettre la construction de droits
collectifs pour les travailleurs des
plateformes de fait ça n'est pas dans
les compétences de la Commission
européenne de réguler le travail
indépendant et donc c'est bien une
approche qui peut être complémentaire de
celle qu'on mène en France puisque
finalement ça permettrait si ce texte
aboutisse que nous souhaitons évidemment
de clarifier les critères de
qualification soit on est dans le champ
du salariat et dans ce cas là il y a des
protections habituelles des salariés qui
s'appliquent soit nous n'y sommes pas et
donc c'est tout le champ de la
construction de droits collectifs qu'on
a mené en France avec les différents
textes que j'ai mentionné donc comme
vous savez sans doute un corps et père
c'est réuni hier qui n'a pas montré de
majorité pouvant se dégager sur ce texte
donc peut-être que ce sera le cas d'ici
au prochain conseil epsco on verra si il
est possible d'obtenir un accord sur le
texte à ce moment là
sur les propositions de transparence qui
sont évoqués qui ont été évoqués au
cours de des travaux de votre commission
d'enquête
il y a pas de doute sur le fait que le
mandat qui est confié par les citoyens
aux élus exigent en contrepartie de la
transparence donc c'est notamment le
sens de la loi que vous avez mentionné
la loi la loi Sapin 2 anticorruption de
décembre 2016 et puis les lois pour la
confiance dans la vie politique de
septembre 2017 qui sont venus renforcer
cette exigence la question de
l'approfondissement des mesures
destinées à renforcer la transparence de
la vie publique et à prévenir notamment
les conflits d'intérêts fait l'objet
d'un travail interministériel
actuellement dans le cadre de
l'évaluation de 5ème cycle de la France
par le Greco donc vous savez l'instance
européenne qui est en charge d'apprécier
les situations et dans ce cadre il y a
des travaux qui sont en cours sans doute
pas rentrer dans le détail et certains
seront mieux à même d'en parler que moi
notamment par la hatv la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie politique
mais également par le SGG et la dgfp
pour regarder s'il y a encore des pistes
d'amélioration dans ce domaine
merci je voulais aussi vous poser
quelques questions sur bien que vous
l'ayez bien sûr évoqué déjà en détail
sur l'art on a vu déjà des premiers
accords sur vous l'avez mentionné sur
les tarifs minimum des courses VTC des
livreurs c'est que sur les modalités de
rupture du bien commercial entre
plateforme et livreur l'agenda social
2023 négocier et signer qu'est-ce que
vous voyez comme autre piste
d'amélioration de la relation entre les
plateformes et les travailleurs et de la
protection sociale dans les travaux de
l'ARPE éventuellement dans les prochains
mois ou les prochaines années j'aurai
aussi vous interroger sur le choix de
Monsieur Metlin que nous avons
auditionné il y a quelques mois pour
diriger l'arbre vous le savez les vété
mentionnés dans certains articles de
presse dans le cadre de du cabinet
topics il avait réalisé plus de 200
missions de services aux entreprises sur
les questions de transformation du
travail dans jeu
du travail hybride des problématiques de
management et des conséquences de la
transformation du modèle travail sur les
salariés parmi les entreprises il y a
des missions pour pour hacker et donc
pour
uber via takkerney est-ce que ça fait
partie des sujets qui ont pu être
soulevés lors de sa de sa nomination à
la tête de l'organisation
alors peut-être sur les sujets de
préoccupation je pense qu'il
correspondent aux premiers accords qui
ont été négociés par les représentants
des travailleurs et des plateformes
évidemment la question de la
rémunération des travailleurs des
plateformes c'est le sens des premiers
accords qui ont été conclus et puis il y
a par ailleurs
des sujets qui étaient fréquemment
mentionnés par les chauffeurs et par les
livreurs notamment sur le droit à la
déconnexion donc c'est des sujets qui
ont été encadrés dès le départ dans la
loi d'orientation des mobilités avec un
droit à la déconnexion ensuite on voit
qu'il y a encore des négociations qui
peuvent être menées sur ces champs-là et
au delà enfin il appartient pas vraiment
de définir les champs dans lesquels les
travailleurs des plateformes souhaitent
des améliorations ils ont des
représentants qui sont là pour eux
exprimer leurs attentes peut-être
souligner que c'est
finalement un opérateur assez
particulier un harpe puisqu'on
on est dans une démarche qui vise à
permettre à des travailleurs
indépendants de créer des droits
collectifs et il nous a semblé important
qui puisse y avoir au moins au démarrage
un accompagnement à facilitateur du
dialogue social peut-être que une fois
que les
modalités de discussion entre les
représentants des travailleurs et les
plateformes seront rodées on pourra
constater qu'il y a plus besoin d'avoir
cette forme de de facilitateur du
dialogue social je voudrais aussi
effectivement répondre à votre question
s'agissant de Bruno Mettling donc je
pense qu'en toute transparence chacun
sait qu'il a en effet effectué une
mission pour un cabinet de conseils qui
était lui-même en contrat avec
uber je enfin quand j'avais confié
la mission de préfiguration de l'arbre à
Bruno metlinks avait été très clairement
indiqué et à l'époque on avait voulu
équilibrer
ta composition de la mission avec une
travailleuse indépendante et un membre
d'un signe tank auteur d'un essai
intitulé désubérisé reprendre le
contrôle donc vous voyez qu'il y avait
une certaine diversité dans la
composition de cette mission qui visait
à après figurer l'arbre je voudrais
souligner que tout le monde ne pensait
pas forcément que ça pourrait être le
cas mais finalement quand on voit que on
a eu cinq accords entre les travailleurs
des plateformes et les plateformes en 7
mois je pense qu'on peut être assez fier
de ce qu'on a fait en France et on est
certainement le pays dans lequel on a pu
construire des droits de protection
collectif finalement pour les
travailleurs des plateformes ce qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs donc je
j'imagine que vous avez dû auditionner
des représentants des travailleurs
je pense que l'ARPE à la fois
l'existence des cinq accords montrent
qu'il y a un chemin pour construire des
droits collectifs pour des travailleurs
indépendants et que manifestement l'art
a bien joué son rôle de facilitateur
puisque 5 accords en sept mois il y a
beaucoup de branches dans lequel la
négociation collective ne fonctionne pas
aussi bien
merci c'est en effet ce qu'on a entendu
de la part des représentants de VTC qui
sont représentés à l'ARP ainsi
d'ailleurs que la neutralité de Monsieur
Metlin qu'ils ont souligné dans le cas
des travaux une dernière question de mon
côté
pour prendre un peu de chance sur sur le
marché
le les VTC sont arrivés il y a une
dizaine d'années en fait en France comme
en Europe ou aux États-Unis à l'époque
et c'était déjà le cas dans le cas de
débat avant on a auditionné Monsieur
Attali par exemple sur le cadre du
rapport pour la commission pour
libération de la croissance il y avait
un débat sur l'insuffisance de l'offre
de transport par rapport à la demande
notamment si on comparait la France à
d'autres grandes capitales touristiques
type Londres Madrid New York aujourd'hui
ou au contraire une offre assez
importante VTC mais même taxi avec plus
de taxis aujourd'hui qui a qu'à l'époque
quel regard en fait vous portez
finalement 10 ans après l'arrivée des
VTC sur cet équilibre ibre entre l'offre
et la demande entre les VTC et les taxis
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est arrivé
au fond à un équilibre satisfaisant
aujourd'hui en France en particulier à
Paris
je pense vous l'avez souligné que
l'arrivée des VTC a été un choc pour les
taxis et ça a été le sens des premières
lois qui ont été prises pour mieux
articuler de mode de t3p qui évidemment
pouvait apparaître en concurrence
ça a eu un effet très important dans la
transformation de l'offre des taxis et
je pense que toutes les plateformes qui
se sont développées pour des taxis dont
aujourd'hui enfin finalement il peut y
avoir une même une forme de relation qui
n'est pas très différente entre les
plateformes de taxi et les taxis et les
plateformes
de VTC et les VTC finalement ça a
vraiment tiré vers le haut je pense
l'offre de transport
particulier de deux personnes donc ça a
eu cet effet là ce que je note c'est que
alors que ça a été un sujet qui a été
très conflictuel au départ aujourd'hui
il y a plus de débats sur le sujet et je
pense que vous avez un certain nombre de
chauffeurs de taxi qui parfois font des
courses en lien avec des plateformes VTC
donc finalement je pense qu'on a
globalement amélioré le service
et avec des relations qui de fait
aujourd'hui ne sont plus conflictuelles
entre entre les VTC et les taxis le
champ des livreurs moi en tant que
ministre du Travail c'était un champ sur
lequel j'avais beaucoup de vigilance
parce que
on voit que ça a démarré je l'ai évoqué
sous forme de job d'appoint et c'est
devenu de fait le revenu principal pour
un certain nombre de travailleurs moi
dans les échanges que j'avais avec les
plateformes de livraison
j'avais beaucoup insisté d'abord sur le
phénomène de sous-location des comptes
qui conduisaient à mettre en position de
vulnérabilité à certains nombres de
travailleurs en situation irrégulière et
au-delà de ça je pense pas qu'on puisse
considérer que ça peut être un emploi
durable donc je pense qu'il y aura aussi
et peut-être pour revenir à la question
que vous posiez sur quels sont les
futurs champs de la négociation
collective dans ces secteurs-là moi
j'avais invité des plateformes de
livraison à réfléchir
au parcours professionnel qu'on peut
proposer à des personnes qui démarrent
leur vie professionnelle en tant que
livreur je pense que ça reste un secteur
dans lequel on voit que ça n'a pas
vocation à mon sens à être un emploi
durable ça peut être un coup de pouce au
démarrage un job complémentaire mais je
pense pas qu'on puisse considérer que
c'est sa constitue un emploi dans lequel
on peut penser que chacun va trouver son
épanouissement
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame la Première ministre
finalement votre audition est
extrêmement importante parce que quelque
part vous cochez toutes les cases en
ayant été ministre du Transport ministre
du Travail et première ministre sur
voilà quel a été et qu'elle est la
stratégie du gouvernement français face
au développement de l'ubérisation et
c'est un des sujets au cœur de notre
commission d'enquête parlementaire lors
des auditions précédentes on a pu voir à
quel point finalement la stratégie du
Berre qui à l'échelle de la France mais
aussi à l'échelle de l'ensemble des pays
de l'Union européenne perd un à un les
décisions de justice qui à chaque fois
démontre bien qu'il y a une situation de
subordination entre le chauffeur des FTC
et la plateforme entre le livreur et le
livreur et la plateforme et donc se
retrouve à devoir requalifier enfin se
retrouve face à des décisions de justice
qui exige la requalification en salariés
des travailleurs en fait faussement en
fait indépendant et la question du lien
de subordination s'impose c'est dans ce
cadre là dans ce contexte là que la
Commission européenne a décidé donc de
mettre à son agenda législatif cette
proposition de directive européenne et
face à cela la stratégie du maire a été
dans un premier temps de défendre un
tiers statut ni indépendant ni salarié
puis de développer notre rhétorique qui
vise à dire il faut un dialogue social
il faut de nouveau droit pour les
travailleurs des plateformes et
d'ailleurs
Dara que c'est toujours très dur à
prononcer Drako Chahi le PDG du beurre
avait présenté un better deal et dans
une tribune a pu vanter et prendre en
exemple la France comme modèle pour son
instauration dialogue social et de ses
droits des travailleurs des plateformes
à travers ce qui va devenir par la suite
la création de l'ARPE en fait il faut
bien comprendre que la stratégie des
plateformes c'est on constate des droits
pour ne pas avoir à requalifier en
salarié et le débat sur la directive et
bien dans ce contexte là alors ma
question est la suivante
vos collègues précédents messieurs les
ministres Clément baume et Olivier du
soft finalement on dit que et vous-même
que vous étiez prêt à accepter le texte
de compromis présenté par la présidence
check en décembre au Conseil or c'était
un texte de torpillage de la directive
puisque c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il a
pas eu de majorité qualifiée et sur la
base de cette position qui prévoyait
d'ajouter bien des critères par rapport
à ce que proposait la Commission
européenne des exemptions en plus des
délais suspensifs je pense notamment aux
exemplesions que la France voudrait
mettre en place c'est à dire si un pays
dans insoumise
madame panot vous adressez un courrier
aujourd'hui sans réponse vous demandant
au nom de l'article 50 alinéa 1 de la
Constitution d'organiser un débat suivi
d'un vote à l'Assemblée nationale sur ce
que va être la position de la France
défendue au Conseil de l'Union
européenne les différentes courses dans
un de la nupes ont fait de même il y a
une exigence de transparence et de
démocratie vous comprenez bien que
l'enquête des Hubert-Félix montre que
sur la période des révélations
bières-fives il y avait une totale
opacité des rencontres entre le ministre
de l'économie de l'époque et les
dirigeants du père avec plus 17 échanges
où on a pu voir et on découvre avec
l'ensemble des documents que nous sommes
en train d'étudier transmis par Mike
Magan à quel point il y avait vraiment
toute une stratégie entre le ministre et
le dirigeant d'Hubert pour peser dans
une opacité totale et contre la vie du
gouvernement et aujourd'hui on voit que
vous défendez le gouvernement français
défend finalement la même stratégie
cuber contre la directive européenne
présomption de salariat contre même
d'ailleurs vos députés européens
Renaissance et encore une fois dans une
certaine opacité un débat à l'Assemblée
nationale transparent assortie d'un vote
permettrait de sortir cela est-ce que
vous allez choisir cela ou bien comme
sur les retraites vous à coup de 49-3 ou
de menaces article 40 le débat le
rappelle politique
qui est redéfini à chaque fois lors des
auditions de transparin international
plus il y a de contrôle citoyens plus il
y a de démocratie mieux on organise la
séparation des lobbys et de l'état donc
vous comprendrez ma question
démocratique est un enjeu extrêmement
important et les confédérations
syndicales m'ont bien dites qu'elle
n'avait pas été sollicitée sur la
position de la France la directive
présentation de salariat et souhaite
également se débat je souhaite
évidemment que la première ministre
puisse répondre à ces questions et qu'on
puisse en poser d'autres je j'ai déjà 5
députés qui veulent aussi poser des
questions dont d'ailleurs je précise
de la France insoumise je souhaite que
tout le monde puisse poser des questions
donc j'inviterai vraiment là à essayer
de rester assez bref et de nous en tenir
aux questions mais la première mise
alors c'est original je viens d'entendre
un long exposé de votre part sur votre
point de vue sur les plateformes c'est
enfin si ça vous intéresse d'avoir mon
point de vue je peux aussi exposer le
mien là vous avez exposé le vôtre
longuement c'est assez original dans une
commission d'enquête de finalement
insister quasiment une conférence de
presse mais je vais essayer donc de
répondre à votre question
depuis le départ et j'imagine que vous
avez peut-être auditionné des
travailleurs des représentants des VTC
il se trouve même si ça n'est pas votre
point de vue qu'il y a des travailleurs
qui veulent le statut d'indépendant ils
veulent le statut d'indépendant parce
qu'ils veulent choisir par exemple le
rythme de travail parce qu'ils peuvent
travailler avec plusieurs plateformes
donc ce qui guide la position du
gouvernement ce qu'il a guidé dans le
précédent quinquennat et qui continue à
la guider c'est de dire que on souhaite
permettre à des travailleurs qui veulent
un statut d'indépendant avec ce que ça
suppose par exemple choisir les moments
où on travaille et ceux où on travaille
pas
et il y a eu un certain nombre de
décisions de justice quand il y avait un
lien de subordination donc soit il y a
des critères qui permettent de
il est utile qu'il puisse y avoir une
harmonisation au niveau européen sur les
critères qui peuvent permettre de
requalifier la relation entre une
plateforme et un travailleur en salariat
et dans ce cas là on bascule dans un
champ sur lequel les droits sociaux sont
bien balisés par des décennies
négociations collectives donc soit on
n'est pas dans ce cas là et dans ce cas
là on considère que le fait de ne pas
être salarié ne doit pas empêcher de
construire des droits collectifs pour
les travailleurs c'est la ligne que l'on
tient vous me dites le texte de décembre
2022 était un mauvais texte c'est votre
point de vue ce n'était pas celui que
porter la France ça n'était pas celui du
commissaire Schmitt dont vous avez bien
compris qu'il tient à cette directive et
qu'il avait validé le texte de décembre
2022 donc je ne sais pas ce qui vous
permet de dire que ce texte n'était pas
bon en tout cas ce n'est pas l'avis du
commissaire qui porte ce texte donc la
position de la France elle est
parfaitement transparente je voulais
expliquer est-ce qu'il est pertinent
d'avoir un débat 50-1 vous avez des
semaines de contrôle dans lequel vous
pouvez demander à l'inscrire et pourquoi
pas ce que je note c'est que c'est des
bas là on les a déjà eu longuement on
les a eu au moment du débat sur la loi
d'orientation des mobilités on l'a eu au
moment où on a ratifié l'ordonnance qui
était prévue dans la loi d'orientation
des mobilités si le Parlement souhaite
un nouveau débat pourquoi pas voilà si
ça peut être inscrit à l'ordre du jour
c'est pas forcément je passe simplement
forcément forcément la seule à pouvoir à
pouvoir l'apprécier et peut-être que par
exemple les les parlementaires qui
suivent les affaires européennes
pourraient avoir un avis sur le sujet
madame la Première ministre j'ai posé
une question au ministre du Travail à
laquelle il n'était pas forcément en
capacité de répondre et je pense que
vous vous pourrez plus facilement
vous avez dans un courrier adressé à la
plateforme medif/ qui met en relation
des travailleurs
de profession par de santé et
paramédicaux et des établissements vous
avez écrit une un courrier qui était
cossigné avec Monsieur Veyron lorsqu'il
était ministre de la Santé et vous
lorsque vous étiez ministre du Travail
et dans ce courrier vous exprimiez à la
plateforme edit flash quelque chose de
très clair en état actuel de la
réglementation il n'est légalement pas
possible pour un aide-soignant d'exercer
en tant que travailleur indépendant et
d'être mis à disposition auprès d'un
établissement de santé ou médico-social
sous ce statut et que cet exercice peut
tomber sous le coup de la qualification
de travail dissimulé et d'ailleurs
les services les contrôles de l'URSSAF
et de l'inspection du travail ont été
diligentes dans plusieurs établissements
médico-sociaux je voudrais savoir quel
autre action depuis ont été
envisagées défectuer mais dit flash a
reçu de l'argent de la BPI France 450
000 euros en préamorçage investissement
et 8000 euros de subventions alors même
que la plateforme a reçu ce courrier de
des deux ministères celui de la santé et
le vôtre lorsque vous étiez ministre du
Travail pour faire cette mise en
relation on a d'autres plateformes qui
ont reçu des sommes aussi encore plus
conséquentes notamment la plateforme
brigade qui fait également de la mise en
relation à la fois sur la restauration
mais aussi ceux qui sont de santé
n'y a-t-il pas une totale contradiction
à la fois d'avoir un courrier en tant
que ministre qui montre bien que cette
activité est illégale et de l'autre la
BPI France qui donne les moyens au
développement de des ces plateformes
qu'avez-vous à répondre là-dessus
alors d'une part je vous remercie de
citer cet exemple parce que ça montre
que contrairement à ce que vous avez
l'air de sous-entendre on n'est pas
aveuglément convaincu que toutes les
plateformes de mise en relation
exerce leur activité dans le cadre qui
qui s'impose en effet je vous confirme
vous voyez autant moi j'ai changé avec
beaucoup de chauffeurs VTC qui
souhaitaient être indépendant et qui
exerce leurs activités dans un cadre qui
me semble correspondre en effet à une
activité de travailleurs indépendant
autant j'avais été choqué d'avoir des
plateformes qui mettaient en relation
des aides-soignantes avec des hôpitaux
pour exercer une activité prétendue
indépendante on voit bien que une
aide-soignante je pense qu'on espère
tous en tant que potentiel patient que
l'aide-soignante exerce son activité
sous le contrôle des médecins donc on
voit qu'on a un lien de subordination
et quand j'ai eu connaissance
effectivement de l'existence de ces
plateformes qui mettaient en relation
des aides-soignants supposés
indépendantes avec des directeurs
d'hôpitaux je vous confirme qu'avec le
ministre de la Santé de l'époque nous
avons donné instruction aux hôpitaux de
ne pas faire appel à des
aides-soignantes qui par nature ne
peuvent pas exercer un travail
indépendant au sein d'un hôpital je ne
suis pas au courant de la subvention
dont vous que vous mentionnez qui aurait
été versé par BPI France mais on va
regarder pourquoi enfin à quel outil de
quelle activité cette plateforme a pu
avoir des subventions en tout cas je
vous confirme que il y a des cadres dans
lequel je pense que on peut faire le
choix d'exercer son activité sous forme
de travailleur indépendant et que le cas
des aides-soignants ne peut pas rentrer
dans ce cas puisqu'il y a clairement
l'existence et même la nécessité d'un
lien de subordination donc on voit que
c'est un détournement du statut et donc
c'est illégal
et dans quel action ont donc être
envisagée ou ont été envisagées depuis
ses courriers pour que ces plateformes
ne puissent pas continuer parce que de
fait ces plateformes continuent leur
mise en relation notamment avec des
EHPAD avec les différents établissements
vous comprenez bien que là il y a un
flou complet ou une plateforme en toute
illégalité pour reprendre vos termes
continue cette activité donc on est face
quand même un manquement de l'État de
droit faire respecter le cadre légal
donc quels sont les moyens que vous
comptez mis en œuvre mettre en oeuvre et
je réitère votre ma question à laquelle
vous n'avez pas apporté de réponse
précise l'Union la Commission européenne
estime qu'il y a au moins 5 millions de
travailleurs qui doivent être
requalifiés en salariés notamment les
livreurs et les chauffeurs VTC quel est
votre position à ce sujet êtes-vous en
désaccord avec la Commission européenne
pour Monsieur Schmitt le rapporteur le
commissaire européen cette question
de la présomption de salariat doit être
doit arriver à son terme est-ce que du
coup la position de la France va être de
franchir une ligne rouge et d'être en
désaccord avec cette directive j'ai pas
compris quelle ligne rouge vous
mentionnez franchir quelle ligne rouge
et bien pour le commissaire européen
mais je vous invite à écouter l'audition
que nous avons pu faire ici du
commissaire européen monsieur Schmitt il
trouve que la position de la France et
les déclarations notamment de Monsieur
dussoft en faveur de la présomption
d'indépendance sont une ligne rouge sont
un contradiction totale avec ce qui
engagé par par la Commission européenne
n'a pas exprimé sa position sous cette
forme là parce que je ne pense pas que
le rôle d'un commissaire européen soit
de poser des lignes rouges à un État
membre donc j'imagine que c'est une
interprétation de votre part je
n'imagine pas qu'un commissaire européen
dans le cadre d'une discussion qui se
déroule au sein d'un conseil des
ministres viennent poser des lignes
rouges aux États donc je suppose madame
la députée je suppose madame la députée
que vous avez mal interprété la position
du commissaire européen si vous me
permettez de répondre sur le travail
illégal vous savez que la lutte contre
le travail illégal c'est une très forte
qui a une dimension interministérielle
importante il y a de nombreux corps de
contrôle qui sont concernés la lutte
contre les fausses statues notamment les
faux travailleurs indépendants les faux
bénévoles la fausse sous-traitance sont
des axes majeurs du plan national de
lutte contre le travail illégal et c'est
aussi des enquêtes qui sont
particulièrement complexes qui peuvent
prendre du temps pour qualifier les les
infractions je peux vous assurer que
cette question restera à l'ordre du jour
du prochain du prochain plan national de
lutte contre le travail illégal comme
priorité gouvernementale dans sa lutte
contre le travail illégal voilà donc moi
je suis pas capable de vous dire on sent
les procédures parce que c'est plus tout
à fait dans mes attributions de suivre
en détail l'avancement de ces procédures
mais j'imagine que les ministres
compétences seront à même de vous
répondre ensuite je
[Musique]
enfin qu'elle va être le devenir des du
statut des chauffeurs VTC je crois avoir
essayé d'exprimer le fait que ce qui est
important c'est de qualifier la relation
entre une plateforme et un travailleur
soit on rentre dans des critères bien
connus qui existent dans le droit
français et qui pourrait rentrer dans le
droit européen sur un lien de
subordination et dans ce cas là ça
s'appelle du salariat soit il n'y a pas
de lien de subordination et c'est du
travail indépendant
bien je vous remercie je précise
effectivement que le commissaire Schmitt
n'a pas utilisé ces termes il a
certainement pas porté un regard sur les
déclarations de tel ou tel ministre
français c'est absolument pas ingéré
dans nos propres débats de politique je
propose qu'on prenne les questions de
député deux par deux pour que vous
puissiez y répondre plus rapidement même
la première ministre on a d'abord
monsieur kerbat puis monsieur Gassin
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
la relation du travail ne dépend pas de
ce que veulent les parties mais la
réalité objective de la réalité du
travail c'est pas parce que je veux être
indépendant que je suis indépendant et
vous avez fait une grande défense là de
ces travailleurs que nous connaissons
que nous avons interrogé aussi qui
disent que être indépendant c'est
important pour eux mais ce qui compte
c'est qu'il y a une subordination et
c'est ça que la directive européenne
assume en septembre 2021 à l'Assemblée
nationale vous êtes exprimé contre une
directive sur la principe de présomption
de salariat et on tient à disposition
votre la vidéo de l'époque vous avez
donc changé d'avis ou bien vous êtes
toujours opposé à la directive
ou bien vous avez il me semblait là ce
que c'est la bonne réponse décidez de
vider de sa substance la présomption de
cesariat de salariat comme on a pu le
démontrer avec la proposition de la
présidente de la présidente tchèque la
présomption de salariats dans la
directive à vos propres prises de
position Conseil de l'Union européenne
et j'ai une question très rapide en
attendant l'application de cette
directive qui est nécessaire et qui est
soutenu par la Commission européenne il
y a la question de tous ces travailleurs
sans papier qui sont dans un statut flou
qui sont dans un statut souvent
illégales avec en effet des gens qui
leur vendent des comptes et il serait
peut-être temps à l'aune de la future
loi Asie l'immigration de réfléchir à
des gens qui travaillent dans le pays et
qu'il faudrait peut-être intégrer à la
circulation la circulaire Valls pour
leur régularisation je vous remercie
madame première ministre
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Première ministre alors que les
évolutions économiques du 20e siècle
avait entraîné un déclin du travail
indépendant cette tendance cette
inversée ces dernières années c'est de
volonté bien dépendance des travailleurs
conduits
des conditions de travail dans
lesquelles ils gardent une réelle une
indépendance réelle comment
analysez-vous ce nouveau rapport au
travail comment analysez-vous les effets
économiques qui ont entraîné qui ont été
entraînés pardon par l'adoption du
régime de la micro-entreprise par les
travailleurs comment intégrez-vous
également ces éléments dans votre
politique qui conduit notre pays vers le
vers le plein emploi et dernière petite
question
[Musique]
avez-vous un avis considérez-vous utile
d'étendre au travailleur indépendant
certaines protections qui sont
aujourd'hui fortement enfin liées au
statut de salariés
par exemple une durée maximale de
travail voilà quel est votre position
par rapport à ce sujet je vous remercie
donc
sur le la première question
je suis pas sûr que vous ayez
totalement écouté l'exposé que j'ai
essayé de faire de la position de la
France sur le sujet
on est dans un cadre qui est
nécessairement contraint puisque
l'Europe n'a pas de compétences sur le
travail indépendant donc le champ de la
directive et par nature
forcément limitée
au cas dans lequel
la relation entre une plateforme et un
travailleur créer de fait un lien de
subordination et donc relève du salariat
moi je n'ai pas
aucune difficulté et la position que la
France peut apporter dans le cadre des
discussions sur la directive c'est pas
de s'interroger sur la pertinence
d'avoir des critères européens
permettant de qualifier la relation
entre une plateforme et un travailleur
et de faciliter la requalification en
travail salarié quand c'est le cas c'est
de dire que ça doit se faire sur la base
de critères clairs si les critères sont
flous et qu'à la fin c'est le juge qui
doit se prononcer finalement la
directive n'aura pas apporté d'avancer
par ailleurs ce qu'on porte aussi c'est
le fait qu'on assiste comme vous venez
de le dire monsieur le député à
l'émergence de nouvelles formes
d'activités et qui nous semble important
que le fait d'être des travailleurs
indépendants
ne dispense pas de se préoccuper de
créer des droits pour les travailleurs
concernés donc ce qu'on souhaite c'est à
la fois que on soit au clair mais je
pense qu'il y a de la jurisprudence en
France qui est très voilà parfaitement
limpide sur le sujet sur les conditions
dans lesquelles une relation doit être
requalifiée en salariat et que quand ça
n'est pas le cas parce que ça peut être
un choix d'une partie de nos concitoyens
de vouloir décider librement
notamment de son temps de travail de
l'organisation de son travail de son
outil de travail ça ne doit pas nous
dispenser de réfléchir à la protection
qu'on doit apporter aux travailleurs qui
font le choix d'être indépendant si ce
que madame la députée parlait des
retraites c'est dans cet état d'esprit
là par exemple qu'on a souhaité que les
professions libérales puissent
bénéficier d'une bonification pour leur
retraite quand pour le troisième enfant
et qu'ils auront désormais la même
protection que les salariés pour une
majoration de 10% de la retraite pour
des travailleurs donc qui sont
indépendants
j'ai essayé de répondre enfin
ce qu'on peut constater c'est qu'en
effet il y a une évolution de la
relation au travail et il y a
certainement de la part d'une partie de
nous concitoyens une volonté de plus
d'indépendance et ça peut être un choix
fort de décider de travailler sur
certaines plages horaires de décider
ensuite de ne pas travailler donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on doit
intégrer je pense que ce qu'on doit
avoir en tête aussi pour moi c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut être
vigilant c'est
le fait que les personnes qui font le
choix de ce travail indépendant et bien
en tête les futurs droits sociaux dont
ils pourront bénéficier on évoquait
notamment les personnes qui avaient
choisi qui voulaient
[Musique]
qui travaillait avec une plateforme qui
prétendait mettre en relation
l'hôpital et des aides-soignantes dans
le cadre d'un statut faussement
indépendant les personnes qui faisaient
ce choix-là n'avaient sans doute pas
bien en tête ou en tout cas ne prenez
pas toute la mesure de la plus faible
protection sociale que ça pourrait leur
donner donc je pense que on va pas aller
contre le sens de l'histoire d'avoir une
partie de nos concitoyens qui sont moins
enclins à accepter des CDI j'imagine que
vous avez entendu comme moi des
entreprises qui disent le salarié qui a
un CDD je lui propose un CDI il n'en
veut pas de la même façon vous avez des
travailleurs qui ne souhaitent pas un
statut de salarié je pense que ça doit
quand même nous amener collectivement à
réfléchir à la façon dont les personnes
en question auront demain des droits
sociaux suffisants et une protection
sociale suffisante
merci je m'aime berger madame et ensuite
madame rouleau
oui merci monsieur le Président même la
rapporteur madame la première minute je
vais surtout d'abord remercier Madame la
rapporteur parce que je crois que grâce
à votre audition madame la première
liste ça peut permettre de démontrer
tous les éléments de régulation que la
France a réussi à mettre en place et a
été la première à mettre en place donc
que cette audition est donc
particulièrement intéressante
puisqu'elle nous permet de saluer le
rôle de la France à cet égard dès lors
qu'on a justement une position qui est
de dire que nous on veut réguler et non
interdire et qu'on veut laisser une
liberté de choix tout en accordant une
protection sociale renforcée comment
expliquer vous que la France est réussie
justement à se mettre dans cette
perspective là et que les plateformes et
acceptée aussi un certain nombre de ses
concessions qui sont nécessaires
évidemment pour celles et ceux qui
travaillent deuxième point j'avais
hésité la première audition de délivre
rouge c'est qu'il y en a eu une seconde
parce que la première il y avait un
certain nombre de réponses on va dire
qui était lacunaire et on a évidemment
sur un symptôme de plateforme des
inquiétudes vous l'avez dit vous-même
sur en effet ce qui pourrait être sous
loué notamment et donc la question des
contrôles internes déjà de ces
entreprises est-ce qu'on peut aller plus
loin peut-être sur des éléments de
sanction vis-à-vis de ces entreprises
par rapport à la nécessité de la
transparence qu'elle devrait avoir sur
les contrôles qu'elle mette en place et
je vois que notre collègue de la France
insoumise et donc finalement tout à fait
favorable à la loi immigration puisque
justement sur la question de la
régularisation qui pourrait exister pour
les travailleurs de ces métiers en
tension je vois que vous avez dit dans
notre commission d'enquête que vous
seriez favorable au vote de la loi donc
j'en suis très impatiente je vous
remercie
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur madame la première nuit
ministre
je voudrais en fait vous poser trois
questions mais j'aurais peut-être le
temps de vous en poser que deux je
voulais en préambule rappeler que vous
n'avez pas toujours été tendre
d'ailleurs avec les plateformes puisque
d'après d'après Wikipédia vous auriez
dit lors du Black Friday de 2019 qui
suscitait la polémique en raison de qui
suscitait la limite en raison de ses
conséquences environnementales que vous
auriez donc dit
que c'était d'abord une énorme opération
commerciale des grandes plateformes en
ligne dont vous ne pensez pas qu'elle
soit les petites amies des petits
commerçants donc parfois vous avez été
critiques alors nous ne sommes tous en
fait là au tour de
cette table en fin disons dans cette
salle et nous attendons vos réponses
alors tout à l'heure vous avez dit il
faut réguler mieux la sous-location moi
je vous pose la question donc là cette
question sera courte pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir carrément interdite parce que
c'est vrai que la sous-location de
compte peut permettre la fraude
la sous-location de compte permet la
fraude donc sur cette première question
pourquoi ne pas avoir interdit et si
ça n'a pas été le casque ça pour aller
dans l'avenir
la deuxième question porte sur le choix
indépendant qui a été rappelé tout à
l'heure et vous-même vous avez plusieurs
fois dit moi ce que je ne veux pas c'est
quelque chose de rigide je veux que
quelqu'un qui veuille être indépendant
puisse le rester c'est là la position de
la France vous avez aussi dit la France
a été la plus protectrice en fait et
bien laissez-moi vous dire qu'à de
précédentes auditions j'ai été
comment dire très marqué en fait par les
auditions d'Alexandre Dolle et
dervestridt qui nous ont raconté avec
précision comment quelques fois
certaines plateformes mettaient là
pression sur des livreurs qui au départ
avait avez le choix de l'indépendance
qui au départ se voulait indépendant et
qui finalement n'arrivait pas à ne
serait-ce qu'à vivre de leur bénéfices
donc il nous expliqua en gros vous
écouterez l'audition parce que je vais
pas revenir sur tous les détails mais
que chaque fois ils empruntaient en fait
pour pouvoir parce qu'on leur mettait la
pression en fait pour que
pour que chaque fois le coup soit plus
bas et en fait le coup de la course ne
représentait pas un coût réel et c'est
là en fait
l'arnaque et c'est situations que nous
devons tous dénoncer et après peu
importe s'il y a une présomption en fait
de de pas peu importe mais s'il y a une
présomption de salariat bon c'est
évidemment ces protecteur mais même si
ce n'est pas ce choix qui est retenu par
la France je pense qu'il faudra exiger
effectivement qu'on retienne un coût
réel dans cette dans certains contrats
fait avec des livreurs et que on comment
imaginez-vous justement qu'on puisse
mieux protéger parce qu'actuellement
c'est pas vrai que on est peut-être le
meilleur pays mais quand on a de tels
récits on peut pas dire qu'on est
protecteur et que la France est
peut-être touriste alors que la France
est quand même le pays des droits de
l'homme et on ne doit pas réduire les
gens à une situation d'esclave et
d'esclavagisme donc madame la ministre
le Premier ministre excusez-moi vous
serez d'accord avec moi je pense sur les
avancées qu'il faut faire je vous
attends là dessus je vous attends en
fait sur sur ce que vous envisagez de
faire pour
ces plateformes est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'on leur impose peut-être des
contre-atties ou comment peut-on faire
justement pour qu'on arrive à un coût
réel et à ne pas fausser des
concurrences ma troisième question c'est
tout sur l'indemnisation des taxis de la
licence des taxis mais ça sera trop long
on aura sans doute pas le temps pourquoi
à l'époque ne pas avoir indemnisé parce
que c'était quand même possible de le
faire en prévoyant un fond et puis les
avouer en bien été indemnisés donc voilà
mais ça si vous n'avez pas le temps de
répondre à cette question troisième
question ce n'est pas grave merci
beaucoup de toute façon elle s'éloignait
un petit peu du chant de cette audition
là on l'a déjà bien évoqué avec les
acteurs
à la question de madame la Présidente
Aurore berger je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit conscient que ça n'a pas été
facilement accepté par les plateformes
qu'on veut y mettre en place une
régulation et notamment les premières
avancées qui ont été faits dans le cadre
de la loi d'orientation des mobilités je
pense qu'elles sont venus mettre des
limites à des situations qui n'étaient
pas acceptables enfin il faut se
souvenir qu'avant la loi d'orientation
des mobilités vous aviez un chauffeur
VTC qui devait décider en quelques
secondes
s'il acceptait une course avec la menace
s'il ne l'acceptez pas d'avoir
déconnexion par la plateforme et il
devait accepter une course sans avoir
d'idées de la longueur du trajet qu'il
devait réaliser et la rémunération qui
accompagnait cette cette prestation donc
je pense que ça a été un bras de fer
avec les plateformes pour marquer que
soit les plateformes souhaitaient rester
dans ce genre de situation et donc on
jouerait
la carte du contrôle et de la
requalification soit elles étaient
prêtes à accepter ce que pouvait être un
cadre qui donnait davantage de
capacité de choix au chauffeur et alors
il pouvait y avoir un chemin
correspondant aux souhaits de ceux qui
sont qui souhaitent effectivement rester
indépendant ça doit évidemment enfin ça
fait l'objet de contrôle et ça restera
dans les priorités de contrôle des
différents corps
ministériels et interministériel de
contrôle mais je pense qu'on bâtit un
chemin qui peut permettre à ceux qui le
souhaitent de pouvoir avoir un statut de
travailleurs indépendant avec ce que ça
peut donner comme liberté mais en ayant
une protection je veux dire quelque part
c'est remettre
c'est travailleurs indépendants dans la
situation je sais pas de votre plombier
qui n'accepte pas de faire une
réparation pour une somme qui ne connaît
pas dans des conditions qui ne connaît
pas voilà on remet les choses sur le
même plan et c'est tout le chemin qui a
pu être fait pour obtenir de la part des
plateformes pour placer des plateformes
dans un meilleur cadre de régulation la
question de l'interdiction de la
sous-location très franchement moi je me
la suis posée
il se trouve
que aujourd'hui c'est dans les critères
que la directive propose de considérer
comme un indice de travail
salarié donc en fait les plateformes
nous disent
si vous
obligé enfin si vous interdisez la
sous-location quelque part la
sous-traitance alors vous nous poussez
dans le champ de la requalification moi
je préférais que ce critère n'existe pas
comme un indice de requalification et
qu'on puisse interdire la sous-location
de compte avec toutes les dérives qui
vont avec
et dans le sens de ce que vous évoquez
je pense que c'est aussi important de
dire que dans ce secteur comme dans
d'autres moi je crois beaucoup au
dialogue social et par rapport aux
difficultés que vous mentionnez dans
laquelle dans lesquelles certains
travailleurs notamment livreurs ont pu
être placés c'est le sens de l'accord
sur un revenu minimum d'activités qui a
été trouvée dans le secteur précisément
pour éviter qu'on est des travailleurs
qui à la fin ne peuvent pas vivre
dignement de leur travail et ça montre
que ce chemin de la construction de
droits collectifs pour des travailleurs
indépendants ils donnent des résultats
et en particulier pour les livreurs la
corde sur le revenu minimum d'activité
merci je vais me tourner vers nos
données collègues mais je vais leur
demander vraiment de poser des questions
très rapidement comme ça on pourra
libérer dans à 13h la première mission
monsieur delogu et madame agressif
alors juste je m'excuse mais je suis le
seul ici présent qui était taxi avant
d'être député donc il se peut que je ne
sois pas très rapide parce que j'ai
quand même des choses à dire
permettez-moi déjà de rebondir
ne serait-ce qu'une seule audition avant
celle-ci ça n'a jamais été le cas donc
je vais vous demander là d'être bref et
de respecter les règles du président oui
je comprends très bien monsieur mais à
Marseille il y a des homicides tous les
jours et donc du coup j'ai besoin aussi
de relater d'autres faits qui sont qui
sont importants pour moi en tant que
député mais ne vous inquiétez pas je ne
suis pas là pour pour vous embêter des
jours rebondis tout de suite
sur le mot choc que vous avez dit madame
la Première ministre sur l'arrivée des
VTC ce n'a pas été un choc mais c'est du
fait de votre ingérence à amené à des
suicides de taxi des familles qui ont
été
décimés et précarisés et endetté donc
mesurez vos mots s'il vous plaît je
voulais juste vous dire que l'arrivée du
maire moi j'ai été au premier rang
pendant 10 ans j'ai vécu de cette
activité difficilement madame la
Première ministre du jour au lendemain
j'ai vu arriver sur le marché un géant
capitaliste avec une force de frappe
terrible ces chauffeurs n'avaient pas
les mêmes contraintes je suis désolé je
vous ai demandé de poser une question
j'ai encore une fois
désolé mais en fait depuis tout à
l'heure
respecter vos collègues ou la première
Mini sinon je laisse la parole
mon mandat de député aujourd'hui et
hyper important pour moi en tant que
chien chauffeur de taxi mais je le
comprends mais vos questions qui
aujourd'hui amènent
à allonger le débat pour justement que
moi je ne puisse pas prendre la parole
je suis pas en train de dire je laissais
moi juste prendre la parole s'il vous
plaît je suis un ancien chauffeur taxi
on est dans une commission d'enquête
hubert-five madame la Présidente et
alors je n'ai pas le droit de m'exprimer
mais justement je suis un député taxi et
je pense que je pense que j'ai besoin de
parler mais c'est pas grave je vous
connais à chaque fois que je prends la
parole j'ai droit à ce genre de choses
mais ne vous inquiétez pas je reste dans
ma ligne
en fait c'est chauffeurs n'avaient pas
les mêmes contraintes ne payez pas de
cotisation
casser les prix des courses bref la
concurrence était totalement inéquitable
et complètement déloyée à Marseille face
à cette plateforme qui mettait en danger
notre situation de taxi j'ai pris part à
la grève et croyez-moi ce moment était
particulièrement tendu et difficile
malgré l'arrivée d'un concurrent
totalement déloyal on trouve un accord
grâce à notre mobilisation qui a comme
toute mobilisation un coût énorme pour
nous et du jour au lendemain on l'a vu
on a senti la trahison et l'accord qui a
été cassé par un deuxième arrêté alors à
l'époque on n'avait pas de certitude que
ça venait du ministère de l'Économie
d'Emmanuel Macron pourtant je le sentais
et l'été et l'été dernier quand on a eu
les à la révélation des hubert-fes dans
la presse on a compris qu'on avait
raison tout le monde nous avait traité
de complotistes à l'époque on avait sali
non salinophami sali notre corporation
mais on avait raison donc non seulement
la concurrence entre Hubert et les taxis
étaient complètement inégal mais en plus
Hubert avait un commis d'office qui
était secrétaire général de l'Élysée
puis ministre de l'Économie aujourd'hui
président de la République et cette
personne a choisi de défendre des
intérêts d'actionnaires d'un grand
groupe américain qui ne peut quasiment
pas d'un point en France grâce à des
pratiques fiscales morales j'ai bientôt
fini
la possibilité à la première mise de
vous répondre
je vais je vais vous écouter comme ça au
moins vous entendrez pas l'histoire d'un
député qui a été taxi et qui a des
choses à dire dans cette commission
qu'elle vous n'avez pas participé on
aurait pu vous entendre à nombreuses
reprises je respecte le fait que votre
participation à Marseille quand il y a
eu des homicides monsieur aucun moi j'y
étais tous les jours dans la région
idiotes bon bref de toute façon je vois
très bien à qui j'ai affaire
vous avez le micro madame la Présidente
non donc laissez-moi parler s'il vous
plaît c'est moi qui est la parole
c'est incroyable
non mais j'ai l'impression que à chaque
fois vous souhaitez que ça déborde ou je
laissais moi parler s'il vous plaît je
suis un parlementaire français j'ai le
droit d'avoir la parole en tant que
syntaxie c'est simple quand même
pardonnez-moi madame la Première
ministre de prendre votre temps mais
pour moi c'est le plus important dans ma
vie mes parents ils sont tous taxis j'en
ai besoin
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
bon je vais passer directement aux
questions comme ça au moins je serai
plus rapide et je m'excuse de ces
débordements de vos collègues madame la
Première ministre cette situation qui a
été mise en place par le soutien sans
faille de Macron à Hubert comment
l'avez-vous combattu lorsque vous étiez
ministre des Transports ça c'est ma
première question quel qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait pour répondre à cette
catastrophe sociale comment expliquer
vous que vos collègues de la majorité
présidentielle au Parlement européen se
sont prononcés pour une directive qui
porte à une présomption de salariat
réfragable sans critères alors que le
gouvernement s'y oppose pouvez-vous me
confirmer que les travailleurs
considérés comme des faux indépendants
par la Commission européenne de rester
selon vous sous statut d'indépendant
voilà
je vais laisser la parole à la première
nuit
je sais pas monsieur le député si vous
avez écouté le début de l'audition parce
que je crois avoir essayé de répondre à
vos questions
je pense pas que ce soit le cadre de
vous répondre sur tous les propos que
vous avez tenus que naturellement je ne
partage pas je veux juste vous signaler
que je n'étais pas aux responsabilités
en 2011 ensuite je vous redis que dans
mes différentes fonctions pour le coup
qui démarre en 2017 et non pas en 2011
j'ai
œuvré pour mettre en place une
régulation
dans le domaine des plateformes de
mobilité je vais pas vous redécliner ce
qu'on a imposé comme règle je crois que
je viens de l'expliquer ensuite
s'agissant de la directive européenne je
peux vous redire j'espère que cette
fois-ci vous serez l'occasion d'entendre
ce que je ce que je dis que nous nous
partons de l'idée qu'il y a plusieurs
situations qui peuvent exister des
situations dans lesquelles on a des faux
indépendants parce qu'il y a un lien de
subordination que dans le droit français
la jurisprudence est claire sur ce qui
conduit à requalifier une relation
supposée commerciale en relation de
travail toute une jurisprudence sur le
sujet et on est tout à fait intéressé
que la directive européenne puisse
créer au niveau de l'ensemble des États
membres des critères qui permettent sans
ambiguïté ou facilement de requalifier
une relation commerciale en relation de
salariat quand c'est le cas on pense que
c'est un
démarche qui est important
qui ne doit pas nous dispenser pour les
situations dans lesquelles des
travailleurs font le choix d'être des
travailleurs indépendants et que la
relation respecte ce statut de
travailleurs indépendant ça ne doit pas
nous dispenser de créer des droits
sociaux pour les travailleurs ça a été
ma ligne depuis 2017 c'est celle que je
continue à porter il y a place pour
différents modèles quand on est dans un
modèle qui
affiche qu'on est travailleur
indépendant il faut s'assurer que c'est
réellement le cas donc il y a pas des
liens de subordination qui viendrait
contrevenir à ce principe de travail
indépendant mais ça doit néanmoins
s'accompagner de la construction de
droits sociaux de protection pour les
travailleurs concernés et je pense que
c'est le chemin qui a été engagé les
cinq accords qui ont été conclus en 7
mois permettent de conforter les droits
sociaux de ces travailleurs indépendants
et je pense qu'il faut continuer dans ce
sens
madame la première minute je vous
remercie de votre disponibilité pour
répondre aux questions de notre
commission d'enquête avec précision
aujourd'hui je précise que si certains
de collègues ont des questions
supplémentaires d'autant que certains
n'ont pas pu poser leurs questions nous
pourrons vous les transmettre et on aura
peut-être d'ailleurs des documents de
documents mais dans l'intervalle je vous
remercie énormément votre présence et je
vous souhaite une excellente journée